Good as RealityCapture's generated models are, sometimes you may want to fine-tune them in a DCT application.
This may be because you want to adjust geometry in a certain way, or because you want to rework the UV mapping more efficiently.
This video will show you some of that process, and I'll use the dyno head we generated earlier in this course as an example.
You have a version of this dyno head in the downloadable file that has been provided to you.
As a side note, if your PC cannot find the associated images when you open a project, you need to point to the folder where they reside.
If the model is displaying vertices only, you can switch to Suite mode in the View menu.
Here, I'll export the dyno head as an FBX file and save it to a temp folder.
I'll be using 3ds Max as an example of a DCC application, but you can achieve similar results with other 3D applications as well.
I'll go ahead and import the FBX file in an empty scene.
The model looks good here, but it is also quite dense.
It would be hard to manipulate, for example to rework the UVs.
It's also uneven in those areas that lack photo data.
Currently, the UVs created in RealityCapture are neatly organized, but you may opt for your own solution.
I think I will simplify the model first by using 3ds Max's Retopology modifier.
I'll set the target poly count to 50,000 to simplify the geometry even further.
After computing, I should end up with a topology that is easier to work with.
Now, this process messes up the original UVs, but that's okay as I'm about to recreate them.
At this stage, I need to apply an Unwrap UV modifier.
Here, I can save time by using some of the automated unwrapping tools or take a moment and rework things manually.
If I opt for the latter option, I would typically use the Point-to-Point Seam function to cut my texture seams exactly where I want them.
After that, I can use the Expand Polygon to Seams function to select individual clusters, which I can then quick peel into the UV space.
But in this case, and to save time, I will simply use the Flatten Mapping method to decompose the model.
This is by no means the best optimized method for UVs, but it will illustrate the point.
Once you have manipulated the model in the DCC app, you are ready to take it back into RealityCapture for further processing.
At the very least, you need to do this to reproject the textures onto the new UVs.
You do this by re-exporting the model, either as a new file or by overwriting the old file you created.
Back in RealityCapture, you want to use the Import Model feature under Mesh Model to import the new model.
It will look weird at first because of the messed up or rather reassigned UVs.
Under Tools, you can use the Texture Reprojection feature and specify which models are to be used as a source and as a target.
The target, or result model in this case, is the latest model I just imported, Model 5.
As a source model to get information from, I'll use Model 4 which I cleaned up earlier before exporting the FBX file.
The default values for reprojection work well, but you may elect to export normal and displacement maps in addition to the texture map.
I'll use normals, but won't be generating any displacement maps for this example.
By re-projecting the textures, I get a nicely textured model yet again, but this time based on the UVs that I created.
In fact, you can view that information inside the Model 5 hierarchy where you can display the original texture,
but also the newly generated ones for diffuse and normal maps.
You'll also note that the new model has 100,000 triangles derived from the 50,000 polygons I set up as a target count in 3ds Max.
This means I'm now ready to export the final model, which I can then import into Unreal Engine.
The original, now unwanted texture may be picked up by default, but you can easily import the newly generated diffuse map as well.
From there, it is easy to make the switch at the material level.
Here, I can place and scale the model up to see it better.
The material will inevitably need a bit of tweaking with a few adjustments to the specular and roughness channels.
You could also consider creating a roughness map derived from the diffuse texture in Photoshop.
You may also opt to control the normal strength with the help of a flatten normals node and a scalar parameter.
Here are a few other scans I did using Reality Capture and Reality Scan.
This brings us to the end of this class. I hope you have enjoyed it.